(bouncy upbeat music)
- Okay, I can do this.
I can...
Who am I kidding?
I'm out of shape, I'm starving.
I've eaten nothing but
baby birds for a week.
The crunch is nice, sure,
but it don't fill you up.
(sighing)
I don't got the strength.
(sniffing)
- Oh, really?
- Bacon?
Bite my shiny metal axe!
Well, let's go already!
You took the words and this
tooth right out of my mouth.
(fast-paced music)
- Ow!
Bunny!
Ow, ow!
Ow, ow, ow!
ow!
(groaning)
(screaming)
(shrieking)
(dramatic music)
(volcano rumbling)
- This is amazing.
Luci, you're a hero.
- Yeah, well I dunno about that.
- Oh my God.
Are you from the future?
- No, I'm from two minutes
ago when you shot me down.
(lighthearted music)
You built it.
Science happened.
- Oh my God!
We gotta get thrones like this.
(enchanted music)
Screw this amazing room.
(door slamming)
(shrieking)
- Oh!
I'll never tell.
- Okay, well I'm kinda busy,
so--
- She's a bear.
Ursula's a bear!
- Dad, she's a big lady,
but--
- No, no,
no, she's an actual bear.
She turns into a lady when
she takes her skin off.
- Wow.
(bell ringing)
- Pardon me.
(bouncy music)
(curious music)
- So, you're saying Bean
behaved so disgracefully at
a formal state dinner that
she nearly set off a war?
- No, what Chazz said was
she nearly chazzed off
the whole chazz-ma-tazz.
Know what I mean?
- I do not, but let that
be entered into the record.
- That's Chazz with five "Z's.
- I think I've done enough court reporting
to know how to spell, Chazz.
(sobbing)
- [Elfo] Bean?
- Elfo!
- I knew you could count on me.
(lighthearted music)